RACHEL GARB: Good afternoon.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
We're really excited
to be here.
I'm Rachel Garb, and I lead
interaction design for
Android's apps at Google.
HELENA ROEBER: Hi.
I'm Helena Roeber, and I led
Android's UX research team
from its beginning
through 2012.
RACHEL GARB: Let's just jump
right in, because we have a
lot to cover.
Let's start with a vision.
"Enchant me.
Simplify my life.
Make me amazing." If it seems
a little touchy-feely, well,
that's intentional.
You see, it's about people.
Now of course, this is
not a revelation--
certainly not to the people
in this room.
Those of us in the business
of creating technology for
people, we're well-accustomed to
thinking through use cases
and analyzing user metrics.
But there's another aspect to
people that may not come up as
much, and that's emotion.
We all respond emotionally to
every moment we experience.
And according to Nobel
Prize-winning scientist Daniel
Kahneman, we experience about
20,000 of these moments in a
waking day.
Now, we don't remember all of
them, but the ones we do are
almost always either positive
or negative.
Now Kahneman and other
scientists are studying the
effects of these emotions, and
here's what they're finding.
Negative emotions, like anger
and fear and hate and shame,
can be harmful to your
health and may even
shorten your lifespan.
Now positive emotions, on the
other hand, like hope and joy
and love, they're an
essential daily
requirement for survival.
They improve our physical and
mental health, and they
protect us from depression
and illness.
So as designers, every decision
we make affects
people emotionally.
Now our team sees this as a huge
opportunity, but also a
responsibility we take
very seriously.
So about two years ago, we
developed this design vision.
Now, you'll notice it's phrased
in the first person.
That's intentional.
We want this to read not as our
vision, but as the vision
that our users have for us.
Now how do we know this
vision is valid?
Well, from all the user research
we've done to date,
which Helena will talk about
in a little bit, it really
boils down to these
three sentences.
So it's a tall order.
What exactly does it mean to
enchant me, simplify my life,
and make me amazing?
Answers can be found in
Android's design principles.
They're based on the same
research that informed our
vision, and they've been
guiding us to create
beautiful, usable, and
innovative designs.
Now, we're certain they can do
the same for you, and that's
why we're here today.
So we're going to introduce you
to these design principles
and talk about why we
believe in them.
We'll show many examples,
including from some
groundbreaking projects, and
we'll talk about how you can
use them with your teams.
HELENA ROEBER: I will now
quickly go through the
principles.
And don't worry if I'm going
a little bit too fast.
We will later spend a lot of
time on in-depth examples that
explain each of them.
The principles are grouped
into the three pillars of
Android's vision.
"Enchant me" is about filling
people with joy, showing them
beautiful visuals and graceful
motions, letting them
customize their space, and
letting them directly touch
objects and interact
with them.
And here are the four design
principles for "Enchant me."
RACHEL GARB: Delight me
in surprising ways.
HELENA ROEBER: Real objects
are more fun
than buttons and menus.
RACHEL GARB: Let me
make it mine.
HELENA ROEBER: Get to know me.
The second pillar of Android's
vision, "Simplify My Life," is
about making things easy for
people, making their world
simple to navigate, explaining
it in clear words and
sometimes even with pictures,
and bringing attention to what
is essential.
And here are the eight
principles for "Simplify My
Life."
RACHEL GARB: Keep it brief.
HELENA ROEBER: Pictures
are faster than words.
RACHEL GARB: Decide for me, but
let me have the final say.
HELENA ROEBER: Only show what
I need when I need it.
RACHEL GARB: I should always
know where I am.
HELENA ROEBER: Never
lose my stuff.
RACHEL GARB: If it looks the
same, it should act the same.
HELENA ROEBER: Only interrupt
me if it's important.
And finally, the last pillar,
"Make Me Amazing," is about
making people feel capable,
strong, and smart, giving them
things that they would love to
show off to their friends, and
making them feel like they're in
charge of this powerful and
magical force.
And here are the five principles
for "Make Me
Amazing."
RACHEL GARB: Give me tricks
that work everywhere.
HELENA ROEBER: It's
not my fault.
RACHEL GARB: Sprinkle
encouragement.
HELENA ROEBER: Do the heavy
lifting for me.
RACHEL GARB: Make important
things fast.
HELENA ROEBER: Next, I'll talk a
little bit about the origins
of the design principles, how
we realized we needed them,
how we developed them, and the
difference that they made once
we started to apply them.
During an extensive UX research
project called the
Android Baseline Study,
consisting of diaries, in-home
interviews, and observations,
we saw the profound effect
that technology design had
on people's lives.
This photo here is one of our
engineers at one of the
in-home visits.
We saw when, how, and why people
were using computers,
tablets, and mobile devices.
And we saw that technology had
become so pervasive that
people had started to schedule
deliberate offline times and
enforce them so they could spend
quality time with their
family and friends.
We saw joy in people's faces
when they used technology and
something happened that they
considered magical or
something that brought them
closer to their friends or
maybe something that just gave
them a welcome break
during their day.
But we also saw, unfortunately,
the flip side.
It turns out we tend to blame
ourselves whenever something
goes wrong in technology, and
we realized that all those
non-ideal implementations,
they eroded people's
confidence in their own
abilities and often just
caused sheer frustration.
I'm sure you have all
experienced the same.
I certainly have experienced
it myself.
So this was a call to Android
to touch people's hearts, to
do more of the good stuff and to
fix some of the annoyances
in the product.
So the entire Android UX team
got together and started to
unpack what wasn't working
and why, and we came
up with a long list.
And to be honest, because the
team had such high aspirations
for their work, it was a
little bit of a bummer.
So Rachel and I, we looked at
each other, and we thought,
what if we turn this long list
of shortcomings that bum us
out every time we look at it
into something that actually
inspires us to create beautiful
and usable designs?
So we took the long, negative
list of shortcomings, and we
organized it.
We painstakingly wordsmithed
and crafted it to be short,
memorable, and in the
voice of the user.
Let me give you an example.
One of the insights from this
baseline study was users are
overwhelmed by options and
limitless flexibility.
So our first try at rewording
this was "Don't overwhelm me
on the first date." So you can
see, we actually have a lot of
fun with this.
But in true iterative design
fashion, this was
not the last version.
So we gave it one more try, and
we came up with "Only show
me what I need to see." And this
was pretty close, but it
didn't have that time element
that is actually really
important to progressive
disclosure.
So we gave it one more try,
"Only show what I need when I
need it," and this
was a winner.
This is one of our design
principles that we have today.
We started to use the design
principles during Android's
Ice Cream Sandwich release,
which is the biggest
qualitative jump in Android's
user experience to date.
Two years later, they are still
serving the team well.
What they do is they remind the
team what good design is
all about, and they give the
team a common language to talk
about design in terms
of people.
And finally, they help the
team to tap into people's
emotions and to specifically
design for those emotions.
Many of the principles are aimed
at avoiding negative
emotions in people.
For example, "Only interrupt me
if it's important" prevents
users from feeling
annoyed or angry.
Others are geared at triggering
positive emotions.
"Let me make it mine" makes
people feel more at home.
So the design principles give us
designers control over the
emotions that our products
trigger in people
when they use them.
And this is important, because
from all our research, we know
that our mobile devices have
become almost as close to us
as our best buddies, our
partners or colleagues.
They wake us up in
the morning.
They entertain us and make us
productive during the day, and
they even tuck us into bed.
So it makes sense to take a
closer look at research that
examines relationships
and emotions.
Psychology professor John
Gottman at the University of
Washington has done extensive
research on marriage.
And he did this one study where
he was able to predict
whether a couple would stay
together or not after
observing them for only 15
minutes shortly after they got
their marriage license, and he
was right with 94% accuracy.
So that's pretty cool.
So how did he do it?
So his predictions were based
on a simple formula.
And his predictions, actually he
checked back 10 years later
to see whether he was right.
So his predictions, they were
based on a simple formula--
the ratio of positive to
negative emotions.
He predicted that a marriage
is heading toward a good
outcome when that ratio
is close to 5 to 1.
And he predicted that a marriage
is heading toward
divorce when that ratio
is closer to 1 to 1.
Other people, like the
psychologist Marcial Losada,
has done similar research in the
workplace as director of
the Center for Advanced
Research
in Ann Arbor, Michigan.
And he found that work groups
that have a positive to
negative ratio of 3 to 1 are
significantly more productive
than work groups that don't
reach that ratio.
Another psychology professor,
Barbara Frederickson, she runs
a lab at the University of North
Carolina, Chapel Hill
called the PEPlab, which stands
for Positive Emotions
and Psychophysiology.
She found that we need three
positive emotions to lift us
up for every negative emotion
that drags us down.
Does this apply to design?
Absolutely.
Think about how common it has
become for people to spend
more time with their technology,
their mobile
devices, and computers than
with their partners.
And the message for designers
is clear.
All those little annoyances
in your product, they're
unfortunately not so little.
They have the power to
erase all the magic
that you have created.
RACHEL GARB: Here's a way
to visualize this.
Imagine we have two
jars side by side.
One is a positive jar, and
one is a negative jar.
If we trigger a positive
emotion because we are
excelling at a design principle,
we put one marble
in the positive jar.
If, on the other hand, we
trigger a negative emotion
because we are ignoring a design
principle, we put not
one, not two, but three marbles
in that negative jar.
Now, once the marbles
go in the jars, they
can't be taken out.
But the difference in
amounts in each jar
can change over time.
If both jars have the same
number of marbles, it does not
mean our job is done.
Heck, research tells us we're
barely out of the doghouse.
And if this were a marriage,
we'd be halfway to divorce.
So what we're really after is
to fill the positive jar and
keep the negative jar empty.
HELENA ROEBER: Let me give you
an example of visual motion.
So we all know the Android has
multiple Home screens.
And if you reach the end of the
final Home screen, this is
what happens.
The screen tilts a little
bit and changes color.
I'll get back to that design
in a little bit.
I'd like to just explore a
couple of other ways to solve
that design problem of
communicating that we've
reached the final screen.
What if we did nothing when we
reached the final screen?
How would that feel?
I know how I would feel.
I would probably keep tapping
it, and then eventually I'd
give up, thinking that I
did something wrong.
And even though this was
probably not the most
important event in my
day, there would be
this nagging feeling.
What did I do wrong?
So let's see how we're doing
with the design principles.
We missed the boat on "I should
always know where I am"
and "It's not my fault," because
I just blamed myself
for doing something wrong.
So that's not so good.
That's six negative marbles, and
we would need six positive
marbles just to get
kind of even.
Let's try something different.
What if, when we reach the last
screen and we try to go
beyond it, we pop up a little
message that says, "This is
the last screen"?
It turns out whenever we pop up
something on screen, it's a
little bit like being nagged.
And in the worst case, it's like
being shouted at, and it
takes us out of what
we were doing.
And now, we have to read the
words, understand them, and
try to decide whether we need
to act on the message.
So how are we doing with
our design principles?
We still get three negative
marbles for "It's not my
fault," because I
just got nagged.
And there's more.
We also get three negative
marbles for "Only interrupt me
if it's important." So even
though this design has more
feedback, it's not necessarily
a better design.
Let's look at the
actual design.
When people encountered this
in user studies, they just
kept playing with it.
They just really seemed to enjoy
how it changes colors,
how kind of the physics
work out.
And it was really clear that
people enjoyed what they were
doing, and they enjoyed
interacting with it.
Not only did it tell them that
they did everything right, it
also kind of helped establish
the virtual spaces.
And it provided this feedback
in an elegant, subtle, and
non-disruptive way.
So how are we doing with
the design principles?
So the things that were
previously an issue are no
longer, so negative marbles.
Yay.
But we do get positive marbles
for "Delight me in surprising
ways," because this interaction
was just really
enjoyable, as we could see
in the user studies.
We also get a positive marble
for "Sprinkle encouragement,"
because we just encouraged
people to interact with the
device through touch.
We get a positive marble for
"Pictures are faster than
words," because there
are no words used.
And we get a marble for "Give
me tricks that work
everywhere," because this is
a pattern that is applied
throughout the platform.
So if you work in design, you
know that creating a beautiful
and graceful animation like
that is not simple.
And our motion and visual
designers, they spent many
iterations to get this
interaction just right.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL GARB: A segue to
another topic, words.
So one of the principles that
Helena just mentioned was that
"Pictures are faster than
words." Now, to be clear, the
principle is not saying that
we should never use words.
Of course, there are many things
that words can say that
pictures can't.
But the wrong words can
really backfire.
So some error messages, they
just scream at us, right?
They talk down to us, make
us feel like idiots.
And some welcome messages when
you open up a new app, boy,
they try way too hard
to impress us.
They act a little too chummy,
or maybe they
ramble on and on.
When it comes to shaping
emotions,
words are truly powerful.
That's why the Android design
team has a dedicated writer,
and he's taught us to pay
attention in particular to
these three principles
when we write--
"Keep it brief," "It's not
my fault," and "Sprinkle
encouragement."
Let's look at a few examples
of each of these.
So say the user has just signed
in to their new Android
device, but they have to wait
a moment because we're
connecting with Google servers
to authenticate the account.
Now, we could say it like
this or like this.
Here, we're describing only
what's necessary and nothing
more, and we've eliminated
redundancy.
And that's an example
of "Keep it brief."
Another way we keep it brief
is to help people skim by
putting the most important
thing first.
That way users get a taste of
the main idea right away.
So if Larry Page is your best
friend, that's more important
than the 76 other people.
"Keep it brief."
Next example.
There was a time, admittedly,
when we had a setting with
this label.
And I cringe just
seeing it now.
But we've changed it, and
now it says this.
Much cleaner, right?
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL GARB: When we write for
the UI, we like to pretend
that we're talking to someone
who is smart and competent but
may not speak the language
very well.
So we use short words, active
verbs, and common nouns.
And we avoid technical jargon.
It makes people feel like
they're not smart enough to
use our products.
This is an example of
"It's not my fault."
And speaking of "It's not my
fault," here's an example of
what not to say in
an error message.
Even if the user could have
prevented the situation from
happening, we never point
it out, and we
certainly don't shout.
So here's a better way that
doesn't even feel like an
error message anymore.
"It's not my fault."
OK, another example.
We have a feature in Android
called Face Unlock that keeps
your device secure with
facial recognition.
Now, if a face isn't recognized
for whatever
reason, we need to display
a message.
Now, we could say
it like this.
It's direct, but it's a
little off-putting.
Or maybe inject some humor.
But here's how we
actually say it.
We talk directly to the reader
using second person with
contractions, just like we do
in casual conversation.
Now, by using a tone that's
human and approachable, we are
sprinkling encouragement
in the form of words.
Now what about humor?
Well, for some products and
brands, it's perfectly
acceptable--
maybe even expected.
But Android's an operating
system.
Our voice has to fit with
a very wide variety of
situations and people, and that
makes humor a more risky
proposition.
Now while we strive to be
friendly, we don't go
overboard with being polite,
because too much "hello" and
"please" and "thank you"
everywhere can get to a point
where it really exhausts
the reader.
So go for just a sprinkle
of encouragement.
So to avoid negative emotions,
we write with these three
principles in mind.
But even ahead of that, we ask
ourselves, do we need to write
anything in the first place?
Now we already talked about
looking for ways
to say it in pictures.
Here's something else we do.
If we're thinking about having
a dialogue that asks "Are you
sure?" we'll just do it and
then offer a way to undo.
And that's our principle "Decide
for me, but let me
have the final say." Oh, and
by the way, our team has
banned the use of the phrase
"Are you sure?" because it
places blame on the user by
presuming that they didn't
think something through.
So again, "It's not my fault."
Now, I want to switch topics and
show you an example of how
principles influenced a feature
called Android Beam.
Does everybody know
what that is?
OK.
Well, for those who haven't
heard of it, I'll just give
you a quick background.
We released this in Ice
Cream Sandwich.
It lets you quickly share
information with someone else
simply by touching your
devices together.
It's really great for sharing
web pages, YouTube videos,
photos, contact info, things
like that, and it's one of the
Android projects that I'm most
proud to have worked on.
We designed it with the future
in mind-- a future where
everyone's Android devices
could beam and every app
developer does something
useful or cool with it.
Now let's say I want to
share this picture of
Lulubelle with Helena.
We just bring our devices
together, and that puts us
directly into a mode
for sharing.
I don't have to choose
anything from a menu.
But you may be wondering, what
if I didn't know Helena, and
we're crowded together on a
subway, and our phones are in
our pockets?
Could I accidentally pocket
beam that photo?
And at the same time, could
Helena accidentally send
something to me that
she didn't want to?
Well, the answer is no.
Because once the devices are
together, I confirm with a
touch, and then the
beam happens.
And that's an example of "Decide
for me, but let me
have the final say." Here,
Android decided that when two
phones are put back to back,
somebody probably wants to
share something.
But it won't happen unless a
sender touches to confirm.
Now because we've stripped down
on-screen interactions to
the bare minimum in Android
Beam, we've made it the most
effortless way to share.
When two people are in the same
physical space, Android
Beam avoids extra steps that
both the sender and receiver
would have to take with
emailing or texting.
And that's an example of "Do
the heavy lifting for me."
When the devices come together,
sound and vibration
let you know Android Beam
is ready for you.
[ANDROID BEAM CONFIRMATION
TONE]
RACHEL GARB: And that's a
sprinkle of encouragement.
Now, if Beam doesn't work for
some reason, like the devices
pull away before anyone could
send, the sound indicates that
in a gentle way.
[ANDROID BEAM REDO TONE]
RACHEL GARB: And that's an
example of "It's not my
fault." Now, instead of choosing
from a dialogue that
says, "Do you want to beam your
screen?" with buttons for
yes and no, you simply touch
an object that's an exact
representation of your screen,
because "Real objects are more
fun than buttons and menus."
Now we excel at this principle
in another way too.
The devices themselves are real
objects, and bringing
them together is kind of fun.
Now the animation that happens
when you touch to beam makes
it seem like your screen is
actually flying into the other
person's device.
It's very satisfying.
And that's an example of
"Delight me in surprising
ways."
Now no matter what app you're
using, when you touch to beam,
something always happens.
If the developer of the app
didn't implement any special
behavior, then by default we
just open the app on the
recipient's device.
If the recipient doesn't have
that app, then we launch the
Play store to the exact screen
where they can get it.
And that's an example of "Give
me tricks that work
everywhere."
So as you can see, even when
a user interface is pretty
minimal, like Android Beam, it
can be shaped by a lot of our
principles.
HELENA ROEBER: Our last example
is about the leading
edge of interface design.
I am honored that I got to
participate in creating what I
consider one of the most
exciting new developments in
user interfaces, Google Now.
It's an interface, as you
probably know, that aims to
make your life better by
predicting what you need at
any given moment.
It came out last June
with Android's Jelly
Bean software release.
Google Now is accessed by
swiping up from the bottom of
Android's Home screen
like this.
And then, beneath the search
box, it displays
context-dependent cards
that show you
information that you need.
For instance, most people's
lives involve many logistical
challenges, and Google Now can
show you how long it takes to
go to work, when your package is
getting delivered, or what
the weather will be, all
depending on your context.
What makes Google Now innovative
is that it goes
beyond traditional interface
conventions, and it pushes
some of our design principles
further than most interfaces.
One of those principles is
"Delight me in surprising
ways." Imagine you love where
you live, like I do, or maybe
you're visiting a place that
you always wanted to visit.
Google Now changes the
background of Google's search
box to beautiful art pieces,
depending on where you are and
what time of day it is.
When people encountered this
first in user studies, we
observed pure joy.
And later on, we saw
that same joy every
time that header changed.
It was a very clear success,
and it's a good example of
"Delight me in surprising
ways."
Here's another one.
Imagine you've spent a long
day in the city walking
around, and you just would love
to have a warm drink.
I personally like
hot chocolate.
Google Now will show you the
restaurants nearby, and one of
them may just have that
hot chocolate
that you've been craving.
And this is another way that
Google Now scores points for
"Delight me in surprising
ways."
Another design principle that
Google Now exceeds at is "Do
the heavy lifting for me." For
example, flying abroad can be
a big production, and Google
Now finds ways to make it a
little bit easier for you.
It will let you know if your
flight is delayed and will
give you time maybe for
an early dinner.
Good example for "Do the
heavy lifting for me."
Another example.
So once you're abroad and you're
jet-lagged, it's often
kind of tricky to do
time zone math.
Because you're awake when nobody
else is, and you're
sleepy when you're supposed
to be awake.
So Google Now does something to
help you out with this by
showing you what time
it is at home.
Another example of "Do the
heavy lifting for me"
Another example.
We decided to go for a lean back
experience with Google
Now with almost no setup,
because we knew that if you
had to tell Google Now about
all your preferences in
painstaking detail, it would
kind of spoil the fun.
So now, this is all you have
to do to get started.
It's "Do the heavy lifting for
me." And instead, Google Now
implements the principle
"Get to know me."
In fact, it's all about "Get to
know me." If you drive to
work, you probably have
a preferred time.
And most of us would very much
like to know if there is an
accident or just if there's
bad traffic
that they could avoid.
Google Now learns about your
habits, cross references it
with traffic and other
data, and adjusts
what it shows to you.
It sounds kind of easy when I
say it, but I think you know
it's clearly not.
We're giving the design
principle "Get to know me" a
serious workout.
Most interfaces would implement
this design
principle as maybe remembering
one user preference.
Google Now completely
reconfigures itself based on
automated data triangulation.
Here's another example.
I like freshly baked bread.
And there's a bakery close to
where I live that sells
delicious bread, and I
go there quite a bit.
Google Now has learned that
this place might be of
interest to me and is giving me
the choice to get traffic
to that place.
Another good example for
"Get to know me."
Here's another one that Google
Now pushes to its limits.
"Only show what I need when I
need it." We have simplified
Google Now to the point where it
only shows content when it
has something to say, and it
will show nothing when there's
nothing to say.
It's a pretty bold move.
It looks like this.
And it applies "Only show what
I need when I need it" to
almost everything in the UI.
Here's another example
of something similar.
Whether you're traveling or
not, weather is usually an
important topic.
And there's a million details
one could show--
precipitation percentages, air
pressure, humidity, and so on.
On the weather card, we've
stripped everything down to
its bare essentials.
And it's another example of
"Only show what I need when I
need it."
There are a lot more principles
applied in Google
Now, but these are
the ones that it
really pushes very far.
RACHEL GARB: From the examples
we've shown you, you can see
the tremendous impact that the
design principles have had on
Android's user experience, and
we hope you're inspired to
bring them back to your teams
and try them too.
Is there a specific process
that you should use?
No.
Your design team has its own way
of doing things, and the
principles can fit into
whatever that is.
So instead of process, let's
focus on activities--
things that we all do,
like exploring design
solutions to a problem.
If you're having trouble getting
started, you could
scan the principles and see if
any sticks out to you as
relevant to the problem that
you're trying to solve.
This could help generate
ideas.
Or if you don't have that
problem-- you've explored and
have come up with several
approaches--
you could evaluate each of
them in terms of the
principles and see which
one does best.
And then, take your winning
approach, and see if you can
improve upon it even more by
excelling at more design
principles.
So a few weeks ago, I was in a
really heated discussion about
design with a product team,
and we had two competing
interaction models.
We'd been sitting around
probably for 90 minutes.
It was getting to
be dinner time.
And it just hit me all of a
sudden, and I said to the
group, hey, you know what?
This is really a battle between
"I should always know
where I am" and "If it looks
the same, it should act the
same." And once we recognized
the principles, we started
looking for a way to excel
at both of them.
And we did.
We arrived at a new
interaction model.
Now, here's another thing that
we all do or the designers
that you work with do, which
is presenting designs.
And when you present designs,
you could bring along the
principles for everyone
to refer to.
As the designer, you could quote
from the principles to
explain your thinking or
defend your choices.
You could also encourage others
to point to principles
when they give you feedback
or ask you questions.
So I'll never forget the time
that I presented my first pass
of a design for Android Beam
to my fellow designers.
The first thing I told the team
was that I was focusing
on the "Enchant me" pillar of
our vision for this feature,
and everybody was very excited
to see what was next.
And then, I showed a screen
where you could touch one of
two buttons to indicate
whether you
were sending or receiving.
Now, the immediate reaction was,
understandably, you call
that enchanting?
It teased out an important
principle that I'd been
overlooking, which is "Real
objects are more fun than
buttons and menus." And that
moment was pivotal for the
design of Android Beam.
Here's something else
we all do--
research.
And it can come in handy in
several ways to use the
principles.
When you're developing your
research plans, you could use
the principles to help you
determine your goals.
And then, when you're delivering
the findings from
your studies, you could use the
principles to name reasons
for what you observe, both the
successes and the failures.
And Helena can tell you
all about this.
HELENA ROEBER: Yeah.
So when we developed Google Now,
one of our primary design
goals was to be delightful.
So when we ran this one study,
we actually started to keep
track of all the moments where
participants voiced either
delight or disappointment
or frustration
or were just neutral.
And it was a really nice way for
the team to be reminded of
their original vision, but
also to see how they were
doing with respect to it.
And identify the places that we
should definitely keep and
develop further, but also
find the places
where we can do better.
RACHEL GARB: And here's one I'm
sure everyone in the room
is very familiar with--
prioritizing fixes, especially
at the 11th hour.
Here, you could use the
principles to help make your
case for what's most
important.
And the principles might also
help you identify some quick
wins, which are things that you
could easily change that
also pay off well in terms of
excelling at the principles.
HELENA ROEBER: So Rachel earlier
talked a lot about the
importance of words, and you now
know what emotional impact
they can have.
So when you're looking for
something to fix at the 11th
hour, look at how you're talking
to the people using
your product.
And you now know with relatively
small changes, you
can have a big impact.
RACHEL GARB: And finally, when
you're brainstorming the
future of your product with a
group, you could start off by
going over the principles.
It's a really great way to frame
the challenge and also
encourage everyone
to think big.
And I've been doing
this for a while.
The first time I did this,
I organized a brainstorm
workshop with a cross-functional
team to
envision the future of a
particular area of Android.
And I started out by giving a
five minute refresher on our
design vision and principles.
And then, we asked everyone to
brainstorm, what would it mean
for this experience to enchant
me, simplify my life, and make
me amazing, or to excel at any
of the principles they saw?
And the thing I noticed right
away, as people were writing
down their ideas on sticky notes
and handing them to me,
these ideas were phrased in the
voice of the user, in the
first person.
I just thought that
was very cool.
And I was also really excited
to see that everyone was not
really thinking about
implementation challenges or
feasibility.
They were really able to step
away from that as they put
themselves in the shoes of
users and focused on the
vision and the principles.
HELENA ROEBER: We have some
parting thoughts for you.
And we will leave you with three
questions to ponder, and
we'll ask them in the
voice of the people
who use your products.
Are you enchanting us?
Are you looking for ways to
activate the pleasure centers
of our brains with pictures,
real objects, slick
animations, and pleasing
sounds?
Are you bringing a ray of
sunshine into our lives every
time we use your product?
Are you simplifying our lives?
Are you removing all those
things that burn us out--
inconsistencies, being
lost, confusing
messages, placing blame?
Are you keeping our time and
attention focused on what
really matters?
And finally, are you
making us amazing?
Are you creating something that
we want to show off to
our friends?
Are you solving real
problems for us?
And are you giving us the power
to do things that we
never thought we could?
And with that, we thank
you very much.
The design principles are
published on the Android
developer website.
Soon, this slide will change
to a barcode and a link.
Here we go.
So yeah.
And this ends our session.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]